[Music]
in too old to care news oh I can't wait
to give me money I'm right there I'm
already better but I think I'm already
there like five years ago
Oh fine a lot are we caring about
submitted by hi from here hello here a
68 year old man left his wife because
their newborn baby was detrimental to
his health
when newborn baby a newborn how's the
wife 20-some scars a freak yeah how did
that happen
I like lady stones through the eggs and
if she didn't have been applause then
so yes froze your eggs they had been
trying to get pregnant for the past 20
years they should have given time for
starting at 14 eyes already late Wow
yeah so or last few years
I am pop rested like five these full
schedules are way off
you know it implanted very properly yeah
so they actually did in vitro five times
there's no expensive tell exam what do
you do at Indian this is in Serbia by
the way oh we're Serbia
that's like Easter European European in
between the like of Russia and I like
Eastern Europe I really got to get to
know this world map because I don't know
anything I got a surveying sandwich what
was that called again I don't know a
couple clay
yep honest down which I've ever had was
different
it's like this uh it was I think II
think any cuisine even with like the
dead never it's like just ground meat
that has like this kind of slightly
middle-eastern herb with like this
tomato sauce base and then it had some
sort of like yogurt spread on the bread
and the bread was a very fluffy but kind
of crispy a little bit cut a sandwich
from one try it
hahaha we were in uh where was that at
Christmas market looks like a world
market and there's like all these
different countries are booting there
you don't know a little salt I was like
a weird name I forgot would you like
that it was they couldn't speak English
we couldn't see we're like you just
pointed at it yeah we're like [ __ ] let's
hope we're not eating something with
yeah
like I don't know it looked like could
have been ground dog or some [ __ ]
but I was I don't know what that is it
looks good ain't dog nothing
I don't know it could have been dog
coulda been talking brown squirrel I
don't know what the meat must be in a
little it was it was just shredded meat
that's the best way to eat though you
don't know what it is you surprised Oh
check this out you know when the
appetizers came out for your guys's with
Dean
yeow-kee right quick thing Labine yo
eyes look over there eighth floor and
lovely love paint it like three times
brutally Wow but you like that you like
that's good although enough don't sound
like that's duck liver wait he was
killing it dude he's not - it does that
potato good great is that we can enjoy
them as much as her I was full but
before like dinner came I was going down
you got to make a round good apps on the
dinner though the dinners like whatever
compared to Alex - we screwed up we
forgot not to get beef in France but
yeah that's a aundrea but oh no I guess
very sudden photo shoot the whole time
that they were eating at the time it was
so deadly geez chicken skewers they had
caprese they had flaw with apricot jam
talk about food again god I'm really
well he started act okay but you want
that experience and it was good
everything in Tunisia
what's that [ __ ] you I guess with all of
you guys and she was yeah
yeah Oh on the screen I'll take it a
[ __ ] in the middle of it hey guess what
I'm doing like what take it a pool ha ha
ha ha
Mansell cannot read the room huh
everything [ __ ] though anyway back to
these this couple I don't know what you
guys do so the 60 year old your name is
a Tifa and what people and her husband
is service oh yeah
so they have been trying forever right
to have a baby be finally she was
finally able to carry a baby to term
they had a baby girl and then the very
outer milk inner titties the [ __ ]
shemitah naughty poster we for Holly
firfer data formula right after she gave
birth pretty much like the next day and
there's no like almost out oh why you
serious yeah cuz after how many years of
marriage I'm not sure I'm gonna be me
after Tommy honey yeah at least 20
because yeah then the baby came out he's
like I'm not gonna do this he says I am
a sick man
I am 68 I'm a diabetic when I had a big
heart it is not easy to sleep all night
and to hear babies cry she got what she
wanted now she's happy talking about the
way yeah he's a [ __ ] so he never wanted
the king uh it doesn't seem like it
seems like it was just like you do you
was just doing it for her so here they
aren't a piece of shite while he is
really old while she is really old how
did they get it on I don't love in vitro
all right right yeah yeah or the his
come no why would they do that I know I
was kind of right allocated copy of that
big fella Gator 60 1668 how come she
never had a kid or she or she did they
were trying to 20 years yeah we should
blow it - why did she start at 40 I
don't know nobody would bang her
I don't know but would like hearing the
threat out I was kind of low-key pissed
because I'm like how selfish are you
yourself that you're bringing a new life
into
world I was pet when the babies ten or
some [ __ ] you sack of [ __ ] it's not good
at all
yeah when he's born an orphan basically
go see a change born an orphan
theoretically very much seriously she
lost her [ __ ] virginity at 40 years
old that's [ __ ] what do you think
nobody would bang her I'm so serious
that this selfish old lady yeah she's
also very you should have adopted when
okay cool I can't do it at 40 let me
adopt 40 kids better yet I got the
monkey what a [ __ ] monkey in a diaper
the logic isn't grab a baby be still
it's a monkey just shave the baby yeah
so there's a messy earn a modest pension
and that she has to pay off me alone as
she took for her pregnancy treatment
what the [ __ ] but she says this quote
whatever happens if Surrey stays or goes
I'll fight to raise Alena as best I can
to prove it meanwhile I said the same
thing when I read it I will live for her
alone I know will not be easy but I
still think there are good people who
can help me so now she's being dependent
on other people who was so [ __ ]
irresponsible doctor that said yeah you
like seventy dude like you won't die
when the baby is like in elementary
school the one that said money yes
please so in vitro is where it's inside
her though and she cultivates the baby
inside her belly so what happened the
big se egg and they get the sperm in a
lab and they create the the what is an
embryo all right and they stole back in
her system and then they thought in her
uterus okay so it's inside they hope
that it attaches the weird thing is how
does she still have eggs did maybe she's
probably Rose it or she froze I should
do I don't know
she's really selfish also really bad for
this kid they had it for a long time so
not only is this kid going to grow up
fatherless this kids growing up with a
grandma already and this kids not going
to have a fool like adolescence because
it's correct [ __ ] October's mom's
gonna die
the moms pipe might even possibly on the
kids in high school I will say just
don't maybe at least the kids will grow
up in a very loving home because I mom's
gonna love that child in life that's
true only one mom though
amen some people thrive with one parent
that's true no better to have one pair
that loves them fully to have an [ __ ]
dad around it
this child has been born at all yeah I'm
already trying to look at the drivers
I'm trying to get the bright because I
don't wanna probably love this kid like
praying that - let's follow Gio just
killed a kid because they shouldn't be
good no no I'm not saying ecology dumb
thing you should have never have habit
but like the baby's out now so okay
let's try to figure out what to do you
know assassins are pretty good no it's
just act let me go up let's imagine that
this lady has no other family right this
little girl is gonna be enforcement in
like she's going to be it shows up your
role may be a financially stable right
now she's not even financially stable
right now working off that she has a
pension right just the caps alone like
looking for other people to help her now
yeah well let's just hope that like this
girl goes up to kill cancer so then
she's like you know what people think
that my momma shouldn't have me but I
guess what I got a Nobel Peace Prize
page in your face Emile very poor a
personal choice in terms of like mr.
dobisch however I will say this though I
know a lot of babies they're talking
more fucked-up environment than that and
yeah that kid moms crackhead dad's
cracking mom's exact it had been a drug
dealers you know to do so at least like
I'm saying this person has I mean their
personal choice under her life is [ __ ]
up but let's say this one does live for
another 20 years at least that kid will
be stable but it's like what up best
[ __ ] 20 years of their life yeah
I mean she does my October lower credit
she does say that she feels healthy and
she's feeling I just wanted to say that
I bet you she's all [ __ ] up though do
pushing out a baby out that old ass
[ __ ] bug man doing it right now at my
age like oh you just they're like
fighting for your own like nutrients oh
that's right I can parasite it is
apparent I love you very much
but that's literally what it is I mean
that's literally what it is yeah I'm
eating awesome but you have or maybe
she's so old and loose now like their
skin would you hold out it just [ __ ]
thread about regatta crazy if her water
broke and it baby just fell out if you
follow Joe's logic it's not water it's
powder oh yeah
it is really slimy slimy powders like no
like motor oil dick yeah like you're
like not like old people spitting inside
that lady is a great [ __ ] pyramids of
giza dude that shit's oh that's fun dude
I've seen my grandpa spit before that
she took like three days it was like a
Dragonball Z episode trying to power up
know how to collect that space room it's
like a desert tortoise giving birth no I
said that I was very happy that this
child is I was going to have one loving
parent true I'm surprised a baby day
yeah that's true
I surprised the baby didn't come out of
raisin dude everybody at the baby came
out Benjamin Button this [ __ ] got
cataracts oh that that's not funny verse
and then when she is hurting I'll be in
healthy area
baby that's right I know I'm Thomas I'll
be crazy I hope you know she lives a
long life hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discussed just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video it's right up high
you